i'm not going to lie this is a really
tricky recipe i'm kind of scared they
don't call this mental breakdown cake
for nothing we're going in the oven oh
no i'm not so sure about this no
oh my god
[Music]
hi i'm hannah hi i'm matt and we're here
to do a really cool cooking competition
because in my family my great grandma
has this notorious recipe it's called a
chocolate roll and essentially it's a
swiss roll cake it's a really thin kind
of papery chocolate cake that's wrapped
around whipped cream and covered in an
amazing glaze the only problem is we
don't know how she actually makes it the
only recipe we have is something that my
mom wrote down when she was very young
after watching my great-grandma make it
because she never used measurements but
matt and i are going to compete against
each other to try to make the very best
chocolate roll and here to judge our
work is none other than my mom we also
have jackson and wyatt to help back her
up and taste test and we'll see who can
come the closest to my great-grandma's
recipe i'm kind of scared
hi i'm jackie i'm hannah's mom so this
is my grandma gerkin's famous chocolate
roll it is such a special dessert and
it's been handed down in our family for
generations it's a tricky thing to make
if you don't do one step kind of
perfectly you get a flop so i've
attempted this recipe before and it
literally brought me to my knees crying
in the kitchen i am a horrible baker i'm
anticipating a disaster but to even the
playing field since i am a pretty
skilled baker and matt is more of a
novice to make things fair you're gonna
get the recipe he gets two lifelines in
which he can ask my mom for help along
the way with the recipe let's do this
let's give it a shot okay good luck to
you sir bye two hours on the clock now
[Laughter]
i'm going to start by whipping these egg
whites the way this recipe works is the
egg whites get really fluffy and
they add volume to the cake batter this
is almost all eggs there's pretty much
no flour in this there's no substance to
this it's so fragile you know hannah is
a seasoned cook and a seasoned baker
matt has made some incredible dishes but
he hasn't baked i have no clue what i'm
doing here i need to move this to the
bigger bowl i think so kind of small
good choice yeah all right so i see this
powdered sugars divided oh i think i
poured too many in this is only
attempted on christmas and only if the
entire extended family is coming like we
do not mess around with this cake and we
don't make it for regular occasions how
do you feel i feel okay
yep is this good
no
[Laughter]
okay this is what you want look at that
stiff peak oh wow i'm feeling good it's
looking good i think i'm gonna prep my
pan oh god what is this bake at three
point get a lifeline for me because i
know
get my parchment down oh that is really
ugly okay let's move on to the yolks i
can't remember if there's an order for
this i think they just all go in what
are you doing i'm trying to figure this
all
out you have the recipe i know it's like
an encyclopedia i'm just doing all these
i'm going to save this water just in
case i need to thin it out i feel like i
might not need it but maybe i do i don't
know now i feel very confused i messed
up what'd you do i put the vanilla
extract in this so did i
okay supposed to go with the egg yolks
hopefully we didn't ruin the whites okay
i really don't think i need water in
this there's a lot of overthinking going
on here feeling the pressure no
i feel great
what strategy are you shaking matt there
is no strategy here it's called survival
mode okay i'm gonna put this in here
this could be it for me this texture
doesn't look right
it's too loose it looks like diarrhea
and i don't feel good about it hopefully
the addition of these extra whites will
make it look a little better maybe this
is right and i've just never done it
right and maybe what i needed to do was
just like go with it close my eyes and
dive right into it without overthinking
the recipe if you win i have to buy you
raiders tickets ooh
if i win you have to
rub my feet every night for a week and
tell me how good they smell well that's
that's not hard i do that already no you
don't yeah oh my god he has i do
image in his mind that he's always
giving me massages false okay so she
mixed it all together so i'm gonna do
that sometimes you want to ease the
whites into it you don't want to pile
them up with everything well you know
sometimes but not this time i'm telling
you beginner's luck watch his cake's
gonna be like perfect oh god
no why are you using the beaters oh my
god don't do that don't do that oh my
god that's a massacre
it's called a rubber spatula it's easier
with a machine okay my color is way
different
why is you're so white i need all the
batter i can get come on oh god this is
not gonna work it looks like ice cream
okay i'm putting mine in the oven i
think the other big factor in this cake
is watching it in the oven because oven
temperatures vary so widely i think it's
been in here four minutes and it's
looking like it's shriveling up is it
time to cry on the floor oh shoot and
now it's bubbling oh that's not good i
have nothing left like what am i gonna
do this is not good i had to call in
jackie for a lifeline okay
i made a cappuccino flavor look at the
coloring i don't mind it you don't mind
it i don't know anna's looks like that
how did your sketch i don't know i don't
know i use the same ingredients i kind
of added them in different you did
stages i think it's going to be really
good good i'm feeling better now okay
i'm over here with a mud pie and he's
over there getting it smoothed out for
him okay and we're going in the oven i
think i need to take this out i don't
know
i'm gonna put it back in don't look at
it mom don't look at it don't look at me
sorry i did don't look at me all of our
relatives would shake it out once it's
rolled up you're not gonna see that no i
know but it just looks like a bad omen
i'm gonna powder my towel let's see if i
can do this just do what she does don't
do what i do because look at my cake in
the oven right now okay
don't do what i do your mom thinks my
cappuccino color is good matt that's
really good for you kick me while i'm
down it's bouncing back i think it's
done we're going with it i almost just
dropped it right there completely
dropped it okay moment of truth
[Music]
uh-huh all right
[Music]
no
oh my god
oh no maybe i didn't do it long enough
this is really bad i hope my parchment
is edible because it's probably not even
going to come off oh
you want a clean parchment when you feel
it that one's a little messy i'm going
to powder this a little just because i'm
really nervous that it's gonna stick
we're at 12 minutes now oh that looks
good matt don't make fun of me oh my god
okay so now i flip it and pray
oh this side look at that look at that
coloring
it's called burn but okay hey some
people like crunch it won't roll matt
this crunch doesn't roll just like a
baby how is that like a baby
okay do you know how to make whipped
cream i've seen it done before they
don't call this mental breakdown cake
for nothing and stiff peaks if you over
beat it it turns to butter oh god that's
my whipped cream here's mine i guess
it's okay are you ready to
it looks roll flat
flat but that never hurt anybody i'm
just afraid that this is stuck now ours
are the same color the real reason you
trim the edges is so that you can taste
a little sample it's crispy
some people like that like you gonna get
a nice spread are you proud
kinda
all right let's try to roll this oh
mine's ripping okay
oh
it's not accurate it's like not
accurate at all
because that looks really good now it's
the time to concentrate
oh you're doing great
that's looking really good i'm proud of
us let's get the glaze going it smells
like unsweetened chocolate butter so
then you know i had them add a little
extra butter oh i'm gonna heat these up
i'm just gonna do 30 seconds oh it's
popping okay okay cheese what are you
gonna do if you burn the chocolate mat i
like it burnt that's the matte i know
and love oh this is looking nice and
glossy
my arm starts it's looking good it's not
lumpy i should probably just leave it
that ribbon
that's good right looking good looks
like glaze getting this off of here i
don't know if we can all right that was
very fulfilling we're gonna put these in
the fridge let's do this shall we
good luck
okay so we're back our cakes are chilled
and we have our lovely judges wyatt
jackson and miss jackie i think they
both look amazing i both look yummy
totally impressed i love it okay what do
you think about it wyatt uh it looks
darker needle and soft
neater and softer that one is i think
wider and the swirl was nice oh that's a
beautiful roll on those let's just taste
it let's do it nice soft mmm that's
pretty good
yeah i made the whole thing that is
delicious you made the whole thing yeah
second one
way more satisfying oh
it's tasty it's a little different than
the other one what do you think guys
good i taste butter in this frosting
they taste more butter i am surprised
i'm really impressed that you both did
this
so you hold up your finger one if one
was your favorite or two if two is your
favorite okay
one two
three
[Music]
oh
you won
oh my god
this was yours hannah yeah that was mine
i finished the second one i take a
couple more bites to decide
oh boy moment of truth we taste each
other's are we trying yours first
that's really good that is an a plus
tight roll
okay should we try mine
well the whipped cream is better the
cake is a little better consistency
maybe you did so good the transformation
from what you created which was kind of
like cake crouton
to this that's really amazing that was
awesome and it was so fun to challenge
ourselves and for you to try something
new
and now we know that you're a really
good baker so i don't really have to do
it anymore
stay tuned for more
[Music]
you